bonjour à tous
aujourd'hui on va de hegel et du sens de
l'histoire
le sens de l'histoire c'est une
expression que vous avez peut-être déjà
entendu même si tout le monde ne
l'emploie pas dans le même sens
justement
mais en gros le sens de l'histoire c'est
l'idée que le monde évolue dans une
certaine direction
et que cette évolution est non seulement
souhaitable
mais inexorable
abu parce que porteuse d'amélioration
porteuse de progrès avec tout ce que
cela peut comporter de problèmes quant à
la définition de ce fameux progrès
exo râble parce qu elle s'imposerait à
l'humanité sans qu'elle puisse s'y
opposer
nos jours certains parlent de sens de
l'histoire pour qualifier certains
phénomènes politiques ou économiques
des phénomènes de grande ampleur
qu'ils considèrent comme étant la
destination naturelle de l'humanité
par les deux sens de l'histoire
c'est donc dire que la trajectoire
suivie par l'humanité
rien de hasardeuse
n'a rien d'accidentel
traire une conséquence logique et
nécessaire de son développement
en plus c rond que la mondialisation
le sens de l'histoire
parce que l'humanité a d'abord été
localisé à la surface de la terre
quelle entame et des migrations
que ces migrations ont été favorisées
par des inventions techniques comme les
bateaux
rappelons que les premiers bateaux ont
été inventés au néolithique
que ces bateaux ont permis de traverser
les océans pour s'implanter sur des
territoires vierges
que de proche en proche
l'humanité s'est disséminé sur la
planète
au point d'arrivée où nous en sommes
aujourd'hui c'est à dire
de pouvoir se déplacer dans l'autre
hémisphère en à peine quelques heures
si on accepte le double principe
selon lequel premièrement
romain est un inventeur d'objets
technique qu'il ne cesse d'améliorer
et que deuxièmement il en lui un désir
d'exploration pour ne pas dire un désir
de conquête
bien effectivement la mondialisation va
dans le sens de l'histoire
car l'humanité ne pouvait que finir par
se répandre sur la planète
donc voilà un exemple de phénomènes qui
irait dans le sens de l'histoire la
mondialisation
mais il y en a d'autres
certains diront par exemple que la
démocratie c'est le sens de l'histoire
pourquoi bien parce que les peuples
besoin de se structurer autour de figure
autoritaire pour les canaliser
première civilisation était
nécessairement despotique
les souverains de babylone
sont les pharaons d'égypte
qu'ils avaient tous en commun d'incarner
le pouvoir suprême
puis la grèce a commencé à répartir le
pouvoir entre plusieurs individus
ce fut l'aristocratie
fut l'oligarchie ce fut même la
démocratie athénienne
qui était en fait le pouvoir de 10 % de
citoyens
sur 90% de non citoyens
et au xviiie siècle
chose est apparu en europe qu'on a
appelée démocratie
et qui en tout cas sur le papier
aller dans le sens d'une plus grande
répartition du pouvoir politique
même si marx a bien montré qu'il ne
suffisait pas de proclamer la démocratie
pour que la démocratie soit une réalité
et que les droits de l'homme issu de la
révolution française ont d'abord été les
droits de l'homme mme bourgeois
mais au-delà de ces considérations
ce qu'on observe c'est que l'idée
démocratique s'est répandu dans
l'histoire
de manière extrêmement lente et
progressive avec des revirements avec
des retours en arrière
mais elle s'est répandue de telle sorte
qu'on puisse dire que la direction de
l'histoire c'est la démocratie
dire ça
de très importants à savoir que la
démocratie ou que la mondialisation
ne pouvait pas être le point de départ
de l'histoire humaine
elle ne pouvait être que le point
d'arriver
être que le résultat d'un processus
historique
ne peut s'accomplir que par stade
que par eydap
de l'histoire c'est l'idée qu'il existe
des stades de l'humanité des stades
d'évolution de l'humanité
et qu'on n'arrive pas d'emblée aux
derniers stades
les stades précédents sont nécessaires
pour que le stade final est un sens
un peu comme un être humain qui doit
d'abord passer par la naissance puis par
l'enfance puis par l'adolescence avant
d'atteindre l'âge adulte
son l'humanité a connu plusieurs âges et
elle n'attendra l'âge adulte qu'après
être passé par l'enfance et
l'adolescence
emmanuel qu'en disait que le siècle des
lumières est le siècle de l'accès de
l'humanité à l'âge adulte à l'état de
majorité
que jusqu alors l'humanité avaient vécu
sous tutelle
comme un enfant qui a besoin d'un tuteur
1 c'est un peu ça il faut entendre par
sens de l'histoire
à savoir un chemin d'évolution naturelle
et inexorable
est-ce qu'il faut tout de suite préciser
c'est que
faut respecter ces stades d'évolution
il faut respecter la chronologie
d'évolution pour que cette évolution et
du sens
par exemple on ne peut pas demander à un
enfant de penser comme un adulte
donc pas de mandat enfant de raisonner
comme un adulte
puisque pour raisonner il faut avoir
atteint l'âge de raison
et l'âge de raison on y parvient qu'en
sortant de l'âge de l'enfance
un enfant qui pensent comme un adulte
qui se comporte comme un adulte
ça a un côté un peu effrayant
se dit
vite
il n'a pas vécu son enfance
consécutivement qu'il faut vivre sa
jeunesse
que jeunesse se passe comme dit l'adage
pour que l'entrée dans le monde adulte
est un sens
eh bien son
l'humanité a eu besoin de vivre son
enfance elle avait besoin de vivre son
adolescence
pour que son entrée dans l'âge adulte
est un sens
à l'époque
pharaonique le
concept de démocratie le concept de
liberté individuelle ou de droits de
l'homme n'avait aucun sens
alors
on en est ça veut dire l'idée n'avait
pas encore fait son chemin
littéralement
elle n'avait pas encore fait son chemin
dans l'histoire est donc dans les
esprits
si vous aviez part démocratie à l'époque
de l'ancien empire d'égypte
vous seriez passer pour un fou
parce qu'on est dans ce qu'on appelle
une idées anachroniques
une idée anachronique c'est à dire une
idée qui n'est pas en accord avec son
temps
et donc le sens de l'histoire c'est le
fait de considérer que chaque époque est
gouvernée par sa propre pensée
et que les pensées qui ne sont pas en
accord avec leur temps sont soit moqué
soit réprimé
dans tous les cas elle ne survit pas
et c'est très sympa si c'était là dessus
parce que bien souvent
on entend des jugements sur les époques
passées et donc sur les mentalités des
époques passées
ce fonds à travers le prisme de la
pensée de la mentalité du présent
n'a aucun sens
jugé le passé à travers la lunette du
présent
reproché au passé de ne pas être le
présent c'est croire qu'on pourrait
faire un bond par-dessus l'histoire
c'est croire qu'on pourrait s'extraire
de notre propre poste d'observation
et se placer sur une sorte de perchoirs
métaphysique duquel on perd ce vrai le
juste et le vrai dans leur caractère
absolu
mais ça c'est une illusion
c'est une illusion parce que même si on
a tendance à l'oublier nous sommes des
êtres historique
et parce que nous sommes des êtres
historique nous sommes le fruit de notre
époque
nos idées sont le fruit de notre époque
sont le fruit de notre époque
et chaque époque succède à la précédente
prénom avec elle une évolution des idées
et des valeurs partagées
l'un des éléments définition du sens de
l'histoire c'est donc l'idée qu'à chaque
stade d'évolution historique correspond
un stade d'évolution de l'esprit humain
eagle avait une expression pour ça il
appelait ça le zag geisst
en français l'air du temps
l'esprit du temps
en temps des biens
son
esprit du temps
égal et est ce qu'on a elle un idée east
l'heure pas idéaliste au sens où il
rêvait d'un monde idéal
réaliste au sens où il pensait que les
idées gouverner la réalité
que l'esprit
gouverner la réalité
et donc chaque époque possède son esprit
esprit qui structurent et conditionne
les mentalités individuel
vous préférez notre esprit individuelle
est un fragment de l'esprit du temps
oui on peut avoir une tournure d'esprit
qui diffère de l'esprit du temps
on peut être d'un autre temps
mais à la marge
parce que fond dames allemand
sommes les enfants de notre époque
notre mentalité est ancrée dans notre
époque
elle peut se nourrir du passé mais elle
ne se nourrit du passé que dans la
mesure où le passé est incorporé au
présent
que dans la mesure
ou le présent porte en lui le passé
finition le passé et dépassé
pour régalez au sens de l'histoire
le considérer que comprendre l'histoire
andres la marche de l'histoire
c'était comprendre
tueur du monde
vrai que l'histoire ne devait pas
simplement être décrite
qu'elle ne devait pas simplement être
raconté mais qu'elle devait être pensée
pas du tout la même chose
on peut raconter l'histoire sans
comprendre l'histoire
raconter l'histoire c'est dire ce qu'il
s'est passé
penser l'histoire c'est comprendre le
sens de ce qu'il s'est passé
un eagle s'inscrit dans la tradition de
ce qu'on a appelé la philosophie de
l'histoire
elle pas confondre avec l'histoire de la
philosophie
l'histoire de la philosophie c'est dire
qui a pensé quoi à tel moment
c'est dire qu'il y a eu une philosophie
grecque à l'antiquité une philosophie
chrétienne au moyen âge
une philosophie humaniste à la
renaissance etc etc
l'histoire de la philosophie c'est de
l'histoire
comme il y à l'histoire des arts où
l'histoire des sciences
alors que la philosophie de l'histoire
ses pensées le sens de l'histoire d'un
point de vue philosophique
c'est se demander
qu'est ce que l'histoire nous révèle en
termes de sens
quelle est la logique de l'histoire
et d'ailleurs c'est ce qui fait que
souvent on interprète mal l'expression
sens de l'histoire
parce qu'on se dit est-ce qu'il s'agit
sens comme direction ou bien est-ce
qu'il s'agit du sens comme signification
bien les deux mon capitaine
le sens de l'histoire c'est à la fois la
direction de l'histoire et la
signification de l'histoire
tout simplement parce que d'un point de
vue philosophique la direction détermine
la signification
comprenez bien si l'histoire à une
direction
ça veut dire qu'elle n'est pas le
produit du hasard
et donc si elle n'est pas le produit du
hasard elle a un sens
elle a une signification
c'est ce qu'on appelle
sion finalistes
l'idée que les choses ont une finalité
qu'elles ont un but
pour eagle
l'histoire a un sens parce qu'elle a un
but
et le but de l'histoire selon hegel
c'est ce qu'on va tenter d'élucider dans
la suite de cette analyse
alors déjà haut prenons ce que nous
disions tout à l'heure à savoir que
chaque époque était caractérisée par un
esprit du temps par un z gast
et que cet esprit du temps
structure et conditionne les esprits
individuel
c'est fondamental
ses fondamentaux
si on ne reconnaît pas ce principe on
passe complètement à côté d'un des
piliers de la philosophie de l'histoire
à savoir que ce ne sont pas tant les
hommes qui font l'histoire
que l'histoire qui fait les hommes
alors
valoir que j'explique un peu parce que
c'est pas quelque chose d'évident
qu'est ce que ça veut dire que ce ne
sont pas les hommes qui font l'histoire
mais que c'est l'histoire qui fait les
hommes
d'un point de vue strictement factuel
d'un point de vue strictement matériel
il est clair que ce sont les hommes qui
font l'histoire et non l inverse
l'histoire c'est bien la science qui
étudie les événements
or les événements sont bien le résultat
des actions humaines
l'histoire il est écrit que l'amérique a
été découverte par christophe colomb en
c'est bien parce qu'en 1492
il y à un homme qui s'appelait
christophe colomb qui a pris son bateau
et qui a accosté en amérique
alors oui christophe colomb ont pensé
accosté dans les indes oui les vikings
ont découvert l'amérique bien avant
christophe colomb
là n'est pas le propos
le propos c'est de dire qu'à l'origine
des événements historiques il y à
l'action des hommes
histoire sans action
sans participation des hommes à
l'histoire
on est stable
mais ce que nous dit hegel c'est que
l'histoire ce qu'il appelle les grands
hommes
grand au sens de l' influence qu'ils ont
eue dans la destinée du monde
ces grands hommes étaient d'abord et
avant tout
l'incarnation de l'esprit de leur temps
christophe colomb fut l'incarnation de
l'esprit de son temps
l'esprit de la renaissance européenne
qui se caractérisait par l'exploration
et la conquête de territoires nouveaux
de même que napoléon fut l'incarnation
de l'esprit de son temps
parce qu'il fut l'incarnation de
l'esprit révolutionnaire qui donna
naissance à l'état moderne
d'ailleurs entre christophe colomb et
napoléon
véritable grand homme selon hegel
c'est napoléon
pourquoi parce que contrairement à
christophe colomb
napoléon lui savait ce qu'il faisait
donc napoléon était un grand homme
art était un grand homme
parce qu'ils étaient de grands chefs de
guerre
avait le sens de l'histoire et le sens
de leur rôle dans l'histoire
et donc diggle c'est que lorsque
napoléon lance la campagne d'italie
ce n'est pas lui qui lance la campagne
d'italie
thouars
c'est l'histoire qui a désigné napoléon
pour qu'ils accomplissent ce que
l'histoire a prévu qu'ils accomplissent
alors oui c'est un peu étrange dit comme
ça parce que ça donne l'impression que
l'histoire serait une sorte d'entité
consciente qui manipulent les hommes
oui c'est un peu ça
l'histoire se sert des hommes pour se
réaliser
napoléon c'est l'instrument dont
l'histoire s'empare pour avancer
dans cette conception dans cette
conception de l'histoire comme processus
qui s'accomplit par dessus la volonté
des hommes
nous ne sommes que des jouets de
l'histoire
et quand nous croyons agir de notre
propre volonté
eagle nous dit que notre volonté n'est
que la forme individualisé de la volonté
de l'histoire
pour ceux qui ont écouté mon premier
épisode sur schopenhauer rappelez vous
avait dit que pour schopenhauer le désir
sexuel n'était que la traduction
individualisé de la volonté de l'espèce
qui cherche à se perpétuer à travers
nous
on croit désirer mais c'est la vie
elle-même qui désirent à travers nous
schopenhauer eagle ont beau ne pas être
d'accord sur de nombreuses choses
il ya malgré tout un rapprochement
possible entre ces deux conceptions
est ce que nous dit hegel c'est que
plaisir
l'histoire doit utiliser quelque chose
de fondamental chez les êtres humains à
savoir
leur passion
les passions sont le moteur de
l'histoire
pourquoi parce que les passions nous
font agir
parce que les passions nous met en
mouvement
et la mise en mouvement des hommes par
leur passion permet la mise en mouvement
de l'histoire par leur action
les passions créé les actions qu'ils
créent l'histoire
et
si napoléon
un homme épris d'absolu
s'il n'avait pas été un homme passionné
de grandeur
il n'aurait jamais contre l'europe
il faut être fort totalement mégalomane
pour prétendre conquérir l'europe
l'histoire
loin d'un soldat mégalomane
pour réaliser une telle épopée
napoléon n'était pas horreur
napoléon c'est l'histoire en son
c'est quelque chose de plus aucun homme
mais qui a besoin d'un homme pour se
réaliser
pour eagle les passions humaines sont le
moyen par lequel histoire s'accomplit
dans le monde
on continue
toné de la mégalomanie des hommes de
pouvoir
on continue encore à s'étonner de leur
orgueil de leur narcissisme
de leurs prétentions parfois à se
prendre pour des dieux
ce que nous dit hegel c'est que cette
prétention est consubstantielle à leur
rôle dans l'histoire
les grands hommes doivent se prendre
pour des dieux parce que sans ça ils
n'agiraient pas
et s'il n'agissait pas n'accomplirait
pas l'histoire
le grand homme ne décide pas de faire
l'histoire
le grand homme est traversé par
l'histoire sous la forme d'une passion
ardente
le commandent d'agir sans qu'il sache
réellement pour quelle finalité il agit
le grand homme contemple l'horizon
et il voit l'infini
ils ne voient pas que derrière l'infini
l'histoire continue
il ne faut pas sous-estimer cette
passion
rue main et qui consiste à vouloir
entrer dans l'histoire
si vous voulez faire du freudisme facile
on pourrait y voir une symbolique
entré dans l'histoire
sur tomates
expliqué que ce qui entre dans
l'histoire
c'est en réalité l'histoire qui entre en
eux
eagle 10 m rien de grand ne s'est
accompli dans le monde
sion
et non ce n'est pas la raison qui nous
pousse à agir
c'est la passion
or ce sont ceux qui agissent qu'il faut
l'histoire
c'est donc la passion des hommes
mais c'est en l'histoire qui fait les
hommes
au sens où c'est l'histoire qui s'empare
des passions humaines pour avancer sur
son itinéraire
les passions humaines sont le moteur de
l'histoire
alors arriver à ce stade de la réflexion
une caisse se poser
une question fondamentale
car s'il est vrai que l'histoire guident
l'action des hommes
qu'on est en droit de se poser c
qu'est ce qui guide l'histoire
parce que c'est bien de dire que
l'histoire utilisent les passions
humaines pour s'accomplir
c'est bien beau de dire que l'histoire
cherche à avancer à travers l'action des
hommes
mais dire ça
ce que ce n'est pas prêté à l'histoire
des intentions
est ce que ce n'est pas lui prêter une
volonté
comme si l'histoire était consciente de
ce qu'elle faisait
bien oui pour eagle
l'histoire à une volonté
l'histoire est consciente de ce qu'elle
fait
parce que derrière voir il y à un
principe que hegel appel la raison
la raison univ celle
qu'il appelle également l'esprit
et pour eagle si l'histoire a un sens
c'est parce qu'elle est tout hier guider
raison universelle
alors expliquons ça
pour eagle tout est rationnel
tout est rationnel en
tout a une explication
et tout est guidé par la raison
tout a une explication c'est quelque
chose qu'on peut entendre
parce qu'effectivement
votre monde
sur na li té
rien dans notre monde
désobéir à la logique
on peut se comporte et de manière
illogique
trouver les raisons pour lesquelles on
se comporte de manière illogique
c'est ce qu'a compris eagle
l'irrationnel fait partie du rationnel
mais dire que tout lionel
c'est également dire
une raison est à l'oeuvre dans le monde
cette raison
cherche à se diffuser dans le monde à
travers l'histoire
alors j'en vois déjà certains qui fronce
les sourcils
qu'est ce que ça veut dire qu'une raison
est à l'oeuvre dans le monde
est-ce qu'il ne s'agirait pas là d'une
vision davantage mystique que
philosophique
est ce que google n'est pas en train
d'introduire dieu dans l'équation
en le rebaptisant raison pour mieux
faire passer la pilule
peut-être bien oui
peut-être bien
son de comprendre qu'ici
identifie pas à une entité qui jugent et
qui ordonne
dieu s'identifie
ont elles mêmes
à la raison en tant qu elle s'investit
dans le monde
dans les religions dieu est au dessus du
monde
seul dieu
et dans le monde
il le travail ce
de part en part
il est cette raison universelle qui a un
but à savoir se concrétiser
se manifester à la conscience des hommes
en s'accomplissant dans l'histoire
quand nous agissons
nous faisons l'histoire
nous l'accomplissons
après avoir j nous observons les gupta
de notre action
ces résultats sont rationnels car rien
dans le monde n'échappe à la rationalité
sans agir nous permet d'augmenter notre
niveau de conscience
nous accumulons de l'expérience
et cette expérience se convertit en
enseignements
avec plus ou moins de réussite
eagle disait ironiquement
nous apprend que les peuples n'ont rien
appris de l'histoire
c'était une peu désabusé
de dire que les hommes mettent du temps
à tirer les enseignements de leur
expérience
mais c'est pourtant bien l'expérience
qui permet de comprendre
en se retournant sur ses expériences
en faisant le bilan de ces expériences
pour peu qu'on soit attentif et aptes à
l'autocritique
augmenter son niveau de conscience
la raison il celle
ce qu'ils cherchent à se diffuser dans
l'esprit des hommes
qui empruntent le chemin de l'histoire
pour se manifester à eux
peu à peu
chacune de nos expériences 10 duel ou
collective
une étape sur ce parcours de la
conscience
parce que la raison ne peut pas
apparaître en un seul bloc à la
conscience des hommes
elle a besoin de temps elle a besoin
ivre des étapes parce que chaque étape
fait partie du processus d'accès à la
conscience
si je vous enseigne une vérité
et que vous la gober tout cru
sans la vérifier
sans l'expérimenté cette vérité n'a pas
de valeur pour vous
si je vous que l' esclavage c'est mal
avait rien tant que l'esclavagé ne fait
pas partie de votre historique
c'est tout pau de la pièce de marivaux
l'île des esclaves
bien la nécessité pour le maître de
devenir esclave
et pour l'esclave de devenir le maître
pour que l'un et l'autre comprennent en
quoi cette situation n'est pas viable
en quoi elle doit être dépassé
tout tient dans ce en quoi
comprendre une chose est bonne ou
mauvaise c'est comprendre en quoi elle
est bonne ou mauvaise
et pour ça il faut l'avoir expérimentée
parce que la conscience se nourrit de
l'expérience
et que
l'expérience de l'humanité
doit permettre à cette humanité de
progresser sur le chemin de la raison
les souffrances endurées par les peuples
du passé
le despotisme la servitude
la guerre
nécessaire pour comprendre en quoi elle
devait être dépassée
mais elle ne pouvait pas être dépassé
avant d'avoir été vécue
certains trouvent constat cruel
l'histoire n'est pas cruel
elle est
le champ des possibles
et l'humain
expérimente les possibles
ils les explore dans leur intégralité
jusqu à en tirer
jean qui s'imposent
vous me direz on a
c'est par la souffrance
pour savoir que la souffrance est à
éviter
eh bien si
parce qu'une sous
se connaît cance éprouvant
parent
non
par an ce tte horizons
un enfant c'est pas que le feu brûle
tant qu'il ne sait pas brûler
et tant qu'il ne sait pas brûler la
phrase le feu brûle
a pas de sens du point de vue de sa
conscience
faut-il en compte sûrs que l'humanité
doit se brûler
jusqu'à tant qu'elle comprenne que le
feu brûle
oui
c'est le seul moyen
c'est le seul chemin
et le sens de ouah c'est de nous faire
expérimenter tout ce qui est
expérimental
étape par étape
ses perd plus de conscience
vers plus de raison
et vers plus de liberté
la liberté
et le but thouars selon hegel
parce que la raison rend libre
quand notre raison est altérée nous
perdons une partie de notre liberté
nous devenons très fiable
annie paule abl
instrumentalisable
l'expérience que nous confère de la
raison
elle nous fait progresser vers la raison
et c'est le rôle de l'histoire de faire
progresser l'humanité vers la raison
les chemins qu'elle emprunte
rarement des chemins raisonnable
car il faut qu'il en soit ainsi pour que
l'apprentissage est un sens
on ne progresse pas
la consensualité
on progresse dans la conflictualité
eagle appel là le travail du gatif
le négatif comme condition du positif
parce que l'expérience du négatif révèle
la nécessité de dépasser le négatif
c'est la raison à kehl pour eagle
et avance nécessairement vers le progrès
bien même les événements qui jalonnent
l'histoire
ne semble pas forcément indiqué
une amélioration de la condition humaine
parce que le progrès chez hegel n'est
pas une notion
linéaire
le progrès n'est pas r il est
dialectique
il passe par des
on est
par des contres sont
deux parents un pas en r
et
c'est ça qui fait
souvent mal l'idée gallienne selon
laquelle l'humanité va vers le progrès
parce qu'on voudrait que ce progrès
traduisent dans les apparences
pour eagle
le progrès ne se traduit pas dans les
apparences
il se traduit dans les profondeurs
il se traduit
dans le négatif
si l'histoire
c'est parce qu'elle est le lieu du
travail du négatif
par lequel l'esprit se réalise
eagle voyait dans l'histoire trois
stades de l'évolution s'ils ont de
l'esprit humain
l'art la religion
et la philosophie
l'art
c'est l'esprit qui se manifeste sous une
forme sensible
c'est le rapport au corps
la sensorialité
à la main hier
c'est l'enfant de l'humanité
et l'enfant et il pas seul
naître le monde à travers les sens
la religion c'est l'esprit qui se
manifeste sous la forme de la foi
c'est le rapport au sentiment
à l'expérience intime
et à la représentation
c'est l'adolescence de l'humanité
l'adolescent qui vit ses premières
expériences intimes
qui aime
qui espère
qu'ils doutent
c'est l'avis de
puis vient la philo si
l'accès au concept
la raison
l'âge de raison
le dépassement du sensoriel et de
l'affectif
l'entrée dans l'art l'invité
et dans la liberté
comprendre que raison histoire
diable
comprendre
l'histoire est le lieu de déploiement de
la raison chez les hommes
comprendre que plus l'histoire progresse
plus nous progressons vers chance
plus les hommes se rapproche de l'esprit
plus l'esprit
se rapproche des hommes
jusqu'à fille ir
par deux quand
je cite
il n'y a rien
l'esprit rien ne saurait être plus digne
que lui de devenir son objet
l'esprit ne peut trouver la paix il ne
peut s'occuper de rien avant de
connaître ce qu'ils aient l'esprit doit
donc parvenir aux savoirs de ce qu'il
est vraiment et objective et ce savoir
le transformer en un monde réel et se
produire lui-même objectivement
c'est là le but de l'histoire
universelle
l'essentiel est ici que ce but soit un
résultat
l'esprit n'est pas un être naturel comme
l'animal qui est ce qu'il est
immédiatement l'esprit ce produit lui
même il se fait lui même ce qu'il est
son être n'est pas existence en repos
mais activités pur son être et le
processus absolu ce processus médiation
de lui-même avec lui-même et par
lui-même et non par un autre implique
que l'esprit se différencie en moments
distincts se livrent au mouvement et au
changement et se laisse déterminer de
diverses façons ce processus est aussi
essentiellement un processus graduel et
l'histoire universelle et la
manifestation du processus divin de la
marche graduelle par laquelle l'esprit
connaît et réalise sa vérité
tout ce qui est historique est une étape
de cette connaissance de soi le devoir
suprême les sens de l'esprit et de se
connaître soi même et de se réaliser
c'est ce qu'il accomplit dans l'histoire
ce produit sous certaines formes
déterminées et ses formes sont les
peuples historique
chacun de ces peuples expriment une
étape désigne une époque de l'histoire
universelle plus profondément ces
peuples incarne les principes que
l'esprit à trouver en lui et qu'il a dû
réaliser dans le monde il existe donc
entre eux une connexion nécessaire qui
n'exprime rien d'autre que la nature
même de l'esprit
l'histoire universelle et la
manifestation du processus divin absolue
de l'esprit dans ses plus hautes figures
la marge graduelle par laquelle il
parvient à sa vérité et prend conscience
de soi les peuples historique les
caractère déterminé de leur éthique
collective de leur constitution de leur
art de leur religion de leur science
constituent les configurations de cette
marche graduelle
l'histoire humaine est folle
mais elle n'est folle que pour mieux
nous conduire vers la compréhension
et vers la conscience
on ne compte 11
avoir vécu
la chouette de 9 prend toujours son
envol au crépuscule écrit eagle
il voulait dire la queue
les choses ont d'abord lieu
qu'elles se déroulent
et qu'ensuite seulement la conscience en
contre
il faut avoir vécu pour pouvoir penser
q
la philosophie
yves après histoire
le sang
elle après les événements
l'histoire une et le théâtre de la
conflictuelle ite
et cette compte alité a beau être vécue
par l'humanité
comme une douleur
elle est le seul chemin
par le elle l'esprit peut passer
révéler
si l'histoire est rationnel c'est dans
l'ain hur ou le chaos des passions
humaines
un but
nous faire accéder
à la conscience
à la con
que nous sommes l'histoire
à la conscience
que nous sommes
l'esprit
est que l'absolu
nous temps am
je vous remercie
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]